foreign
I'm thrilled to be here with all of you
my name is Jane Woodward
and I have a real privilege at this
moment which is I get to celebrate three
of my friends at once and each of them
have the same three things in common so
those three people are conradine Von
googleberg and this let's see if I can
click the slide
uh conradine Von googleberg Amery Levins
and J.B Strobel all men that I think of
as my friends
so the three things that they have in
common that I'd at least like to call
out because they probably had even more
things in common is the fact that they
all think as Emory would say as
integrative designers or design thinkers
they like to look at things as a system
all three men obsessed with resource
efficiency
and I would say all three men are very
productive or were productive disruptors
I mean so we've got to change things
around here right but there's ways to do
it that are more productive than others
so that's the context for why I have the
privilege of standing in front of you is
because of my relationship with all
three men this slide is devoted to to
contextualizing this talk today and to
talk just a minute about conradine Von
googleberg so conradine was in my
business School class of 1987 and
there's some remarkable people in the
front row who with me when we lost
conradine about a year after we
graduated
we decided it was really important to
honor conradine's Spirit he was a kind
gentle extraordinary man who looked at
the world on that framework that I
talked about he thought about the whole
system
he really cared about resource
efficiency and believe it or not in 1985
when we were in business school there
was no way to recycle anything and it
drove him nuts and he very quietly and
productively disrupted that problem and
worked to solve it so when we lost
conradine we wanted to create an annual
lecture to honor his memory because he
was an extraordinary person and today as
I stand before you there have been over
30 conradine Von googleberg Memorial
lectures all on leadership in the
environment and this today is the latest
and greatest these are this is an
example of some of the remarkable people
and we're adding JB Straubel to that
list today but the person at the bottom
of this list is JB's and my very good
friend Amory Levins
and if you haven't met Amory you're
going to in just a moment because he's
going to introduce JB and he is an
extraordinary extraordinary integrative
designer and if those of you
who've never thought of that as an
identity hopefully by the time I'm done
talking Amy's done talking JB is done
talking you're going to change your
point of view and want to be one as well
so just quickly because Amory is given
the conradine Von googleberg lecture
twice over the last 35 years himself I
want to make sure you all know who he is
he's one of my superheroes and he has a
very accomplished resume he but the most
important things today are the fact that
he co-founded the Rocky Mountain
Institute today known as RMI that he
teaches today which we're going to talk
about in a moment extreme Energy
Efficiency uh here at Stanford winter
and spring quarters with his colleague
Joel swisher and he has a remarkable
spouse Judy who I adore
to back up a little bit I'm going to
give you a little bit of time travel in
1980 I arrived at Stanford to pursue a
two-year master's degree in geology but
my very first quarter I took a class
that I have since been teaching the last
33 years today we call it understand
energy it had a different name at the
time and one of the two required
textbooks was amory's book soft energy
paths which ultimately embraced this
idea of resource efficiency and the idea
we believe it or not would get smarter
over time and we would not keep doing
things the way we'd done them in the
past so this book changed my life I
reached out to Amory Levins back then
the only way to do it was from a pay
phone and we have been friends ever
since and it's been important to me to
support amerie's work
so in 1996 Amery introduced and
published widely on the topic of a
hypercar
and this coincides broadly with while
this is going on and I'm in touch with
Amory and he's coming and giving
speeches about hybrid cars that I'm
trying to help support in the roughly
the same period of time JB Straubel is a
freshman sitting in the front row of my
class in 1984. and I always like the
people in the front row so I like all of
you already and I always want to talk to
them on the first day of class and say
well who are you and what are you up to
and JB told me that he had already
retrofitted a golf cart he had already
reassembled and disassembled a wind farm
I said you're my kind of guy but back in
the same period where Amy's talking
about a hyper car JB's already thinking
about how to reinvent Transportation so
it's really cool that Amory and JB got
to know each other during this period of
time and have become very good friends
now some of you are scratching your head
and saying what's a hypercar
the concept around hypercar at least
what I took away from it is I didn't
really realize at the time that for
every gallon of gasoline that you put
into an internal combustion engine car
one percent of the energy content moves
you
13 percent moves the weight of the car
and all the rest is lost that really
drove me nuts so I'm really grateful to
Amory and to JB for helping us reinvent
transportation
so I put this in here to provide a
Little Giggle and we're going to
contextualize bananas here in a moment
but this is a fun picture it's in my
conference room in my office and off
California Avenue in Palo Alto in 2008.
so for those of you that are a lot
younger than I am what was going on in
2008 well Solar City was formed in 2006
which was later merged into Tesla and
Tesla was only about five years old six
years old something like that and so
there's me there's Amber there's JB
there's our dear friend Guild Masters
who are going to see tonight Who's
taught more students about energy at
Stanford and Stanford's history than
anybody and there's Lyndon Reeve who ran
Solar City or co-rant Solar City so just
a fun picture in time and the bananas
are going to get more context in a
moment so there you go so not only
remember I talked about these three men
who I adore
they have in common resource efficiency
system thinking and productive change so
Amory walks the talk he has one of the
most extraordinary homes in Snowmass
called Old Snowmass Colorado and out of
it he has grown he's on his 80th banana
crop so you know the instinct to grab a
banana when you're around Amory you're
now in on the inside joke
so quick in information tiesment
advertisement for Amy's class which he
teaches with his fabulous colleague Joel
Swisher if you are inspired by what you
hear today uh I really urge you to take
extreme Energy Efficiency which is
taught winter and spring quarter it's
open to people from all disciplines by
intention and in this class it
celebrates what JB and Amory have been
propagating as pioneers and conradine
did too which is let's bring a
beginner's mind to the problems we Face
let's not accept the status quo let's
look at it Anew and afresh and as a very
famous president once said when faced
with a gigantic array of problems when
you're looking for a solution
don't narrow in too tight actually make
the problem bigger look at the whole
system which so many people it feels
like for a long time I kept saying
Tesla's not a car company it's an energy
company it's all about a system and
people looked at me like I was from Mars
but we need as Amy would say if you make
a problem bigger you can get Factor 10
benefits because there's so many
compounding opportunities in that
process
so I'm almost done so this photo means a
great deal to me all three of the people
in this photo are sitting here in the
front row JB and Amory who've been
jamming on resource efficiency together
now for decades and their wonderful
collaborator Holmes Hummel who is
leading uh energy uh
no energy Justice I get that I get it
mixed up Yes Energy Justice program here
at Stanford just transitions energy
equity and just transitions program here
at Stanford and I encourage you to look
up homes if you have not already
so this is when we first kicked off this
energy efficient extreme Energy
Efficiency class which now is at
Stanford rather than at RMI and to close
and with the drum roll Amery as you
start to walk up here I would like to
you know we talked to the the leaders of
this conference talked about optimism
and Amory is a beacon of Applied hope
and I encourage you to go to the RMI
website and at this page that I'm
showing here you can download a fabulous
speech that Amory gave the language of
which I share regularly with my students
and friends but I decided to share an
excerpt for you to just read for a
moment and I would say this is the
Playbook that JB has been operating from
that Amery has been operating from and
that conradine operated from for as long
as he was able thank you so much for
being here and I get to hand you off to
my friend Amory Levins it's been my
honor for a long time to know JB as an
extraordinary
engineer and and human being uh and I
want to
tell you a couple of little things that
he might not get around to in in his
remarks just to give you an idea of what
a master of design he is
uh
there was a Tesla Roadster early model
long time ago you might get to see it in
a minute
based on what a Lotus Elise platform a
nice light one
it had a little problem though it had a
gearbox which kept blowing up because he
couldn't do the top speed and the top
acceleration
and a couple of good gearbox firms broke
their pick on it
and this was kind of a nagging problem
we started to think about gee maybe the
right answer is no gears
so I wanted to I mean if I get this
story wrong I'm sure Jay Beacon correct
me but I understand that one day he came
into the office
and said to his team hey let's end
Source this problem to our core
capabilities and competences we are
electrical engineers and if we can ring
an extra one-third torque out of our
motor
then we won't need the gearbox
and they said well
that doesn't sound right because Uh
something's going to overheat and you'll
have to Band-Aid on this elaborate
cooling system
uh
and they said oh don't worry if
something gets hot we'll figure out what
it is and and we'll give it a bigger
cross-section or a better conductivity
so they did
and the gears went away with big gains
in saved weight extended range greatly
reduced cost and complexity
and this was a great lesson in designing
stuff out that shouldn't be there
because of Sac super reset perfect
Simplicity
is achieved not when there's nothing
left to add but when there's nothing
left to take away
and that became a durable source of
Tesla's competitive Advantage built
deeply into its culture
many many examples of that radical
simplification
one other
story
comes to mind as well
let's see
if I could remember what it is oh yes
one of JB's very first decisions when
they were going to put up the
gigafactory to make lots of batteries in
Nevada
was that there will be no gas pipe
it would have to be all electric it
would run off solar cells on the roof
and his colleague said JB you must be
nuts we're going to need a lot of
processed heat to run this Factory
and everybody knows you do that with gas
because it's cheaper
and he said just watch so it goes off to
the office where Nevada issues air
pollution permits
and in a half hour he gets the permit
because he's not burning anything so
that's easy
comes back with the permit G normally
that takes six months if it's
uncontested I wonder what six months is
worth in the battery business
and then he starts to look at the
process Heat and the biggest process
heat load is continuously redistelling
of solvents that they need to
make the battery
normally this would be done with a
thermal megawatt of gas boilers
he ends up doing it with a single
electric heat pump that would fit under
your dining room table
and it takes 15 kilowatts so that's what
98.5 or something less energy
why because it turns out that the
temperature rise you need the difference
between boiling and Distilling the
solvent is only one and a half Celsius
degrees
it's not a thousand odd degree flame
temperature
you'd think this would be obvious
but somehow it hadn't been noticed
before
one of the more elegant examples of
beginner's mind throwing away your
assumptions of preconceptions
and just taking a fresh look at what's
really needed
I understand
then went through other process heat
loads and it was kind of a similar story
so I just offer that by way of
introduction
to uh
a person I think is one of the greatest
living engineers
uh and doing extraordinary things for
all of us
JB Straubel
I'll try and share a couple perspectives
maybe a little bit of a story or a few
stories of my career and my life and
some of the things I've done and try and
weave That Into You know what I think
are the important topics and lessons of
what we did at Tesla and why and why
that's still so important and today what
I'm doing at Redwood materials
but I think even to take a step back
for me I think it's extremely important
to to really understand what you're
aiming at and to make sure when you're
especially if you're an entrepreneur and
you start getting sucked in the
direction of a company or a problem to
make sure that that you're aligned with
something that really matters and I saw
a quote or two I think in in the
beginning that that you know echoed with
that but it's extremely important and
it's it's all too easy I think to be an
entrepreneur and pretty soon you're
caught up in the current and you're
going in a direction and you don't have
the luxury of really looking and zooming
way out so to me the imperative to
Electrify really our whole world to
transition us off fossil fuels is one of
the sort of guiding True North
principles that's excited me that's kept
me focused and something I just care
deeply about even since before when I
was a student and before
and you know I I know all of us have
seen these graphs but I think uh I'll
take the opportunity to highlight it one
more time because I think this is so
incredibly important
um so channeling maybe Al Gore here a
tiny bit but you know this this is
literally just data this is an
interpretation it's not a model it's
there's really no uh no interpretation
to speak of it's just measured data of
carbon dioxide in the atmosphere and to
me this is really fundamentally the
hardest problem facing facing
collectively Humanity you know this is
going to be something we're dealing with
transitioning struggling investing
toward for for decades it touches almost
every aspect of what we do in such
profound ways you know it still I I'm
immersed in it I think about almost
every day and it still shocks me you
know sometimes when uh driving to work
on like a really cold morning on a cold
morning when you can see condensation
from everything burning natural gas and
if anybody lives in cold climates you'll
maybe have this experience but you
realize that literally every building
every home every structure you know has
you know an exhaust pipe maybe two or
three or four every vehicle
so we're in this world where we're
surrounded by things burning by
emissions it's it's really quite
pervasive and
um you know it's it's an incredible
opportunity but also a little
overwhelming sometimes
and perhaps even more maybe frustrating
you know if we look at that CO2
concentration graph you'd think okay we
have some awareness of this problem
we're really rallying all of this work
towards sustainability conferences like
this startup companies everywhere
you'd think it was getting better
literally we set a world record for CO2
emissions last year
so if we had the analogy of like we're
in a hole you know we're in this whole
digging you know deeper you know the
hole is sort of how much CO2 is in the
atmosphere
we're not stopping digging we're
actually digging at the fastest rate
we've ever dug deeper into the hole so
sitting at the bottom of the hole
digging deeper at the fastest rate ever
and actually accelerating how fast we're
digging
so it's sort of like if you're thinking
in terms of math here it's like the
first and maybe even second derivative
are all wrong on the same problem
and of course the little dip There Is
2020 with kovid even as much as that
disrupted everything that we do which
was quite dramatic it was still a really
really small fraction in terms of how
much we actually have to change and
really quite quickly
so
one maybe funny anecdote here you know
what what does everyone think of when
you you think of the word 420 in this
context this is kind of a financial
business oriented group I think some of
you probably might have some
connotations that people remember well
you know it's probably not the one you
think of that was what I would highlight
but just last month we passed 420 parts
per million of CO2 in the atmosphere
and you know we briefly passed it last
year but we passed it on the way up into
the summer season in northern hemisphere
this last month and I doubt we'll ever
go below it probably in any of our
lifetimes so it's kind of a sobering
thought to think about but that's
it's almost almost certain to not change
you know we'll probably Plateau this we
can work really hard and we can level
this off but it's going to take quite a
long time to come back down so you know
a different interpretation of 420 but
one that I think is pretty important and
fundamental
and before I sort of leave the topic of
big picture stuff I want to just show
this picture because I really I like
this one you see a lot of pictures of
planet Earth and we're all focused on
thinking about the globe and how small
it all is but seldom do you really see
one that's accurately representing the
atmosphere
and this is It's a real picture you know
showing the thickness of the atmosphere
which is almost ephemeral when you see
it from space there's just almost
nothing there it's a few miles thick
and the fact is we live in two
Dimensions so you never really perceive
how how actual thin it is if you could
get in your car and drive 60 miles an
hour straight up we'd literally drive
out of the atmosphere in a matter of
like maybe five to ten minutes you
couldn't breathe anymore
it's incredibly thin even in the speeds
and distances that we're used to
navigating
but again we don't always perceive that
so it kind of feels infinite in our
current lives but my point is we we can
and we very much are affecting this it's
not a big thing that we're all kind of
swimming around in and breathing so it's
uh it's something that I I think again
when you really wallow in that and think
about it and realize that we're all
sharing this you know relatively small
volume that we have to to coexist in it
just seems crazy that we're we're
putting so much uh so much change and
chemistry into it
so I want to change gears a little bit
here and go way back in time and I'll
I'll sort of reverse back to the
beginning of my journey on
electrification and thinking about
electric cars and batteries I realized
I've spent probably a major portion of
my professional career working on
batteries and EVS of one sort or other
but it did not start very glamorously
you know people think EVS were always
these sort of you know fast sports cars
and the sort of uh scene of you know
lots of interesting rallies and stuff
like that but it it was actually much
more of a kind of hobbyist Club you know
when I was a student you know I was off
converting these old bicycles and these
weird funny golf carts this was actually
at Stanford this golf cart I think it
was a sure escort golf cart that I found
and converted somewhere into a different
electric vehicle
but it kind of felt like maybe the early
days of The Homebrew computer clubs you
know this was a topic of super nerds you
know there were enthusiasts who were
kind of hacking and building these
things in their garages and we'd all
take them to tiny little meets and show
them off to each other they were
probably the only 10 people that
actually cared back then
um but you know this was kind of the
Fertile ground for for how we were doing
some Innovation and starting to think
about this stuff
and it was
actually then migrating into Stanford
where some of the more interesting ideas
and a little bit higher Tech ideas
started to happen and there's a whole
thing called solar car racing which was
very formative in my early days still
going on where different University
teams build cars these very streamlined
Ultra efficient kind of hyper car type
vehicles that run entirely off solar
from the Sun on board the vehicle
and Stanford had a team you know it was
a good team
and when when that was all going on when
I was a student it was kind of in the
transition where batteries in those
solar cars were just migrating from lead
acid to nickel metal hydride and then to
lithium ion it was in the early 2000s
so it was it was a very fascinating time
to think about that and it was as a sort
of outgrowth of that that myself and a
handful of other students back then I I
sort of rallied and created this
electric vehicle team here at Stanford
started thinking about how could we
string together literally thousands of
laptop batteries and figure out how to
make them actually power a car
you could actually take one of these
little teeny laptop batteries they'd
just been invented then they were maybe
only a couple years old and they had a
sort of reputation and a reality a
penchant for catching fire if you didn't
treat them just right but the energy
density was phenomenal and it was better
than anything that had come before
so we could measure one of those little
batteries on a bench top we could you
know make a model we could tell that if
you put enough of these together you
could have a vehicle that would suddenly
be competitive it would change the whole
game and would suddenly be something
that people could use it would have
enough range it it could actually power
all transportation
but back to reality you know it was
literally in a student sort of living
room lab like this when we were trying
to to string these things together keep
them from exploding try and make them
safe enough to run a vehicle
so it was kind of in this exact time
frame just a few years later when almost
all these other cars were were you know
using lead acid they were failing in the
market there was nothing really going on
um most this was really the state of EVS
in about two thousand two three four
and these were not desirable cars most
of the oems had moved on they'd kind of
given up on them at the time because
they didn't believe people wanted them
wasn't enough range Etc you know some of
these were extremely efficient this
vehicle the aptero was a was a very
efficient design
but in some ways the the engineers and
designers were such purists and so so
focused on efficiency that I think they
may have alienated some of the market
and the customers I remember doing a
test drive with them and they were so
passionate but the windows didn't even
roll down because it was it was a little
more weight it was too much drag and you
know of course then you couldn't go to a
drive-through you couldn't do all these
things that people you know expected
wanted to do so A beautiful design it
was more efficient than anything that
had come before but because of the
limitations of the batteries they had
there there wasn't enough energy margin
to have the practicality people wanted
so it was in this context it was about
when I met Elon and this was sort of the
beginning of the whole Tesla Journey you
know I met Elon in about 2003 and it was
shortly after he was much less famous
than he is today he was it was shortly
after he had sold PayPal
so he was sort of best known for selling
PayPal to eBay and he had just started
this this crazy rocket company and it
was sort of the first generation of
entrepreneurs starting rocket companies
so it seemed even more outlandish maybe
than it does today when it's it's
succeeding quite well
but he was really the first person and
we ended up having lunch down in Los
Angeles he was the first person that
really immediately understood and
resonated with what could happen and the
potential for putting Lithium-ion
batteries in EVS
so you know we ended up having a long
lunch discussing this and really kind of
geeked out on this whole topic you know
and uh you know kind of conceived of the
concept the idea that we could take the
mod the best Lithium-ion batteries put
thousands of them together
put that into a sports car type vehicle
and make a new vehicle and a new car
company around it and it was only a few
months after this in 2004 that that he
funded the series a round for the for
what became Tesla I think it was about
eight million dollars that was the
entire a round for the company which is
sort of crazy in hindsight but but
that's what it was and it felt like a
vast amount of money
and we rallied around this concept
building what became the Tesla Roadster
it was really the first lithium-ion
powered commercial EV
which again seems crazy this was not
that long ago this was only 2004 less
than 20 years ago and no one had ever
done this before it was the literally
the first there were tons of Skeptics
you know it was brutally hard actually
even though we could take the data and
we could explain and show hey here's why
it can go 250 miles here's the
performance Etc people didn't believe it
you know there were Fierce critics that
said you know these batteries could
never work it was impossibly unsafe you
know they sort of threatened that we
were fraudulent and all these you know
crazy accusations which was bizarre I
mean I I was an engineer and this was
data and we were taking a model and
designing a product but it's a very
emotional thing
um this Roadster you know became the
first product for for Tesla obviously
there was a road map of other vehicles
but this was really the first one that
proved that lithium-ion could work in a
car and it proved that we were sort of
in a different regime of you know
starting to not have it be a
technological problem it was more of a
price issue it was a vehicle design
issue but fundamentally now there was
enough range there was enough energy to
do something useful
so we created a road map of a whole
bunch of other vehicles a so-called
master plan that migrated from the
Roadster to what became then the model S
and the model X and then the model 3 and
the model Y and you know one one vehicle
at a time one sort of model at a time
you know clawed the way all the way from
being this you know tiny team this
ragtag bunch of people in Silicon Valley
toward building you know one of the
largest car companies in the world I
mean it's this incredible story I look
back on it and it still doesn't even
seem quite real sometimes trying to to
sort of realize you know looking around
the world and seeing these cars
everywhere and people driving them but
uh there's a surprising amount of common
Heritage that goes all the way back to
some decisions we made in the very
beginning
um things like cylindrical cells and the
use of you know how we made the battery
safe and maintain that that kind of uh
you know fire resistance in chemistry
tolerance
so I think another sort of
entrepreneurial lesson for me was was to
try and have the the the the the
blessing of very lucky and good timing
but being in a market where it wasn't
overly crowded where there was enough
white space to do really good design
work and not be constantly kind of
bounded by what the other company to
your left is doing or the company to
your right is doing
um or concerned about you know IP
infringement in every which way you know
it Tesla in the early days it was wide
open space you know no one had ever
tried to put lithium in a car
Lithium-ion batteries in a car before so
we had you know huge huge latitude to
design that no one had ever put a
digital AC motor control inverter in a
car so again huge latitude to design
that
and you know the the sort of design
spaces we were starting with seemed kind
of ridiculously broad when I think of it
today you know in today's world you're
kind of optimizing you know a much more
narrow set of the problem
the example Amory showed was uh whether
we had a two-speed transmission or a one
speed and you know two speed was sort of
the common wisdom everybody thought okay
it's a vehicle it must have a
transmission you know you must have to
shift gears and that's how you'd make
the electric motor more efficient
and it was very controversial to get rid
of that you know we discarded the
transmission entirely went away from it
and it became all electronic speed
control
and literally every EV on the road today
I can't think of any that have a gearbox
or a two-speed gearbox I should say so
these simple things became very you know
transformational and kind of defined the
architecture
now at Tesla I had also kind of the the
very lucky job I loved my role there
um I got to be very entrepreneurial and
it was what I enjoyed doing the most I I
sort of was a little bit restless and I
would usually jump to you know kind of
pushing the boundary and trying to
innovate some adjacent technology or
business to what we were doing so I got
to do that multiple times and really
enjoyed that so one of the things I was
particularly excited and proud about was
pushing and innovating some of our
charging networks back then
you know it again seems crazy today when
you're out driving EVS around and using
charging networks and supercharging but
none of that existed
even just as little as maybe 10 to 12
years ago none of that existed you know
a road trip in an EV used to constitute
bringing a sleeping bag and going to a
an RV park or something like that and
plugging in and sleeping next to your
car if you could or on a tent it was it
was very slow
so this was a Brand New Concept doing
fast DC charging it was a Brand New
Concept to have the company actually
build that and invest in it and just
sort of own the problem and say well the
network is part of the product so so we
actually started investing in it we
started building that
and this little route of dots was the
very first route across the country and
we had this again audacious goal where
we wanted to set a world record a
Guinness Book of World Records on how
fast an EV could go from Los Angeles to
New York so we we set out and actually
had an intern go and try and find all
the locations of where each one of these
sites would be we had to kind of control
and convince you know these rest stops
and you know various Highway locations
and coffee shops all across the country
to let us put in these charging stations
but when we did it
a vehicle was able to go and Sprint all
the way across the the country and
literally set these these dramatic World
Records you know that were just never
possible before
and the whole thing you know became
wildly popular customers not
surprisingly just loved it they used it
you know seamlessly it became this very
very simple intuitive thing that kind of
went hand in hand with you know
launching navs into a market you needed
infrastructure it needed fast charging
so
um I don't have any current slides on
this but there's thousands and thousands
of stations now not just from Tesla but
now from probably a dozen or more
different networks and charging systems
so it's really really cool to see how
fast it's almost like wildfire how fast
that has you know caught you know caught
and scaled across the whole country and
world
another aspect that I was you know
really excited to be involved in the
early days was applying those same
batteries we put in the car into the
stationary setting so we had again a
sort of crazy idea that we'd have the
best economics we'd have the best
availability of batteries and integrated
Safety Systems so why not put those into
stationary settings on the grid use
those for for energy storage as well as
in the cars
and you know that started a whole nother
division it started a whole different
business unit designing things like the
power wall and power pack and then a few
different derivatives that have grown
from there now this is I I believe well
over a billion dollars a quarter in
revenue and growing really fast and it's
a critical uh critical way to actually
make the whole grid sustainable we can't
add more solar we can't add a whole lot
more wind especially in California
without also adding storage to begin to
really you know buffer that and deliver
it at times when we can use it
so all of this these major you know
different initiatives sort of reinforced
battery demand when we could have
charging we'd sell more Vehicles when
stationary storage grew it needed more
batteries everything needed more
batteries
and when we launched the model 3 vehicle
you know this was really the first mass
Market electric vehicle this was about
300 000 Vehicles a year when we first
started it and heading toward 500 000 it
was more batteries in the entire world
built at the time more Lithium-ion
batteries so there was this kind of
dramatic idea to invent a whole new
Factory concept A gigafactory
that literally was bigger than the
entire world output of Lithium-ion
batteries in one single Factory
seemed crazy but it was simple math you
know if 100 or 300 000 people bought
this car we needed somebody needed that
factory
so we built it we designed this the
first one was in Northern Nevada and it
was very successful over a lot of years
of working hard to get it to ramp
but it drove down the cost of batteries
dramatically through economies of scale
through integration through vertical
integration of cell to electrode to cell
to module to pack also automation a lot
more software a lot more integration
focusing on the factory and how we built
it some of those systems that amerex
you know highlighted to basically save
energy and save operating cost so this
was very successful
however you know the part that we did
not solve entirely was well sorry one
other point there in the midst of all
this chaos when about 2017 is when I
started Redwood materials and I didn't
have a whole lot of time to focus on
that at the moment you know this was
sort of a an exciting idea that I really
wanted to to put some attention toward
but it was almost in the beginning was
almost just a parking idea a parking
place you know I I wanted to focus on
this but could not while we were still
ramping model three but 2017 was right
in the midst of ramping the gigafactory
and really seeing some of these
challenges
and the the interesting thing that the
factory did was it changed the whole
Paradigm of how the battery cost
structure worked
previously it was defined by the cost to
assemble the battery after the
gigafactory rammed the raw materials the
components determine the battery cost
and suddenly things like all the nickel
lithium Cobalt manganese copper those
now were by far the majority of the cell
cost and all the gray stuff or the
bluish gray stuff is the cost to
assemble it that's the whole gigafactory
cost so we kind of flipped this Paradigm
and suddenly the factory became the
minority and all the other stuff became
the majority
and unfortunately this has caused you
know challenge in the battery industry
because as more gigafactories
proliferated now there's hundreds being
built or in operation around the world
the the pull on the raw materials has
gone so high that now those raw
materials are starting to go up
dramatically in price or at least are
very volatile some go up down
unpredictable
and it's caused the whole battery price
to start Rising again for the first time
ever in the last 12 months even though
we're getting better and better at
building batteries that part of it is
getting more efficient
so to me this was a really key
imperative to why Redwood and why I
wanted to focus on this new company a
new problem
you know I'm really excited to Envision
what the future looks like if we
imagined you know almost a science
fiction future 20 30 40 years in you
know in the future from now
where you know all of these batteries
are going to be in a closed-loop economy
we don't lose any of the materials in a
battery they're fundamentally different
than a fossil fuel type of economy we
kind of have this intuition that when
you put fossil fuels in a car they they
get converted they're gone you never
have them again but when you put
materials in a battery they just sit
there they get used they kind of you
know convert around inside the battery
but at the end of life of the car
they're all still there 98 plus percent
of them can be reused remanufactured and
put back into a new battery
so that's a paradigm shift and when you
realize that the majority of the battery
cost are in those same materials that
can be reused again and again and again
it points toward a future where we can
obviously start reducing the cost of the
battery much further by having higher
recycled material content every single
year
and it seems far away you know clearly
we can't recycle our way to a whole new
Fleet of vehicles we need a lot of
mining to get from here to there
but our focus is on how do we invent the
most efficient most uh direct most
Capital efficient way to do that
remanufacturing and Recycling and Link
it all the way back into new production
so that also by the way dramatically
reduces the environmental impact of
those battery materials there's you know
perhaps 80 percent reduction in the
emissions and the CO2 to reprocess
materials from an old battery versus
Mining and using Virgin materials
and this is all even more and more
relevant because the this increasing
demand for Batteries is not slowing down
it's it's almost stratospheric it's
really quite hard to even really rock
the scale of this today but looking
toward you know the end of just this
decade I mean we're aiming at around two
terawatt hours of battery demand it's
just a phenomenal amount of batteries if
you remember that first gigafactory was
only about 40 or 35 gigawatt hours and
it was the biggest ever and now we're
talking about thousands so it's the
scale of this and the impact on the
world is really quite vast
now the other problem is this supply
chain is currently strewn all over the
world it's a mess you know this is what
it looks like today for battery
production largely in North America you
know these mined materials are coming
from wherever they're found geologically
they need to be transported mostly to
Asia to be converted into components for
those batteries then sent all the way
back perhaps to North America to a
battery Factory so all of these
Transportation links take a ton of time
they have a high Capital cost they have
a high risk of disruption they're also
geopolitically challenging there's many
issues with this
again a closed loop system has this
really beautiful aspect that it can
collapse all of this you know suddenly
the materials are in the same Market
where you need them they don't have to
go very far in space or time and if we
can invent a really efficient very fast
way of reprocessing and moving them back
into the supply chain that's the kind
that's the future that we're all heading
toward
now at Redwood we sort of have three
major business units I won't spend too
much time on this but it's almost like
three companies sort of integrated with
each other we have a recycling business
that goes and collects batteries from
consumers wherever we can find them we
have a refining business in the middle
that separates all the valuable Metals
apart purifies them really makes them
back into usable materials and then on
the other side we remanufacture we make
components sort of valuable
sub-components that can be used again in
a battery
and the timeline for the company has
been dramatic you know I never expected
actually that this would be quite such a
center of attention you know I saw I
thought we'd sort of be working on
recycling architecture for maybe a half
a decade quietly before anyone really
noticed but uh quite the opposite you
know the whole world I think has woken
up to the the supply constraints and the
the critical Metals constraints so we've
been growing very quickly I again won't
go through every one of these Milestones
but you know we're we're focused on a
series D of funding right now we have
maybe around seven or eight hundred
people we have multiple campuses that
we're we're building kind of
simultaneously and
um also are now in a position where
there's enormous political will and
support for this in the U.S like there
never was before so you know we've been
lucky to have strong support from the
Department of energy you know we were
the recipient of a of a at least a
conditional commitment for a large loan
from the Department of energy to help
ramp these facilities and to help make
some of those Investments
so it's it's been an exciting history
and and I love being an entrepreneur you
know for me that's part of the fun you
know many people asked you know why on
Earth would I possibly leave this you
know CTO role at Tesla it was this
wonderful job people would would fight
for this role
um and it was it was fabulous but I love
being an entrepreneur and as Tesla was
scaling and growing and becoming hugely
successful it was exactly what we always
hoped it could do being an entrepreneur
was was harder and harder and it was
different and you can't really simulate
that inside of a big company you know
try as big companies might you cannot
simulate it it's not the same there's
not that real fear of death you know you
can always sort of go back to you know
okay if this this new thing fails I'll
just go back and work on the other thing
in a startup it's different it's Clarity
of focus it's it's really quite pure
so this is a short flow sheet you know
we basically recycle all these different
feedstocks all the way from old consumer
batteries old EV batteries we mix those
with some new materials there are some
mined materials and make things like
cathode material and copper foils a lot
of components most people don't think
about but they make up a lot of the cost
structure of a battery that goes inside
your electric vehicle
I'll skip over some of this because I
don't want us to be too short on time
here but maybe one point on collection
of these batteries
you know it's actually quite a
Grassroots activity there's no
regulation in the US right now that even
requires people to recycle batteries you
know it's perfectly legal and most
batteries actually get thrown in the
garbage people just literally Chuck it
in the garbage it goes in the landfill
so you know we're out working quite hard
and trying to Almost Do advocacy around
recycling on the front end of the
company you know increasing recycling
rates you're making this easier for
people adding some technology to this
around sorting and collections so that
it's even lower cost to scale this but
it's really really crazy to me that we
would go through all this work to do
exploration a permit of mine dig up the
Earth refine the materials make it into
a product and then throw it away it's
just kind of crazy when you zoom out
from it so being able to keep every one
of those precious you know bits of you
know material that we went through all
the trouble to make in my in the first
time seems like just such a natural
thing we have to do
and to give you a sense of scale you
know also a lot of people sort of think
oh how could there possibly be enough
batteries to make this relevant yet this
is a view of of one of our uh actually
our main you know processing facility in
Nevada these are pallets each one of
those is maybe a thousand pounds you
know it's like twice the size of this
Podium full of batteries
so this is just a small snapshot of the
batteries coming back in the world and I
kind of challenge you to look at your
life you know think around you and think
how many things in your nearby life you
have a Lithium-Ion battery in them it's
quite shocking you know it's it's you
probably have two or three of them on
your person at the moment and then you
go home and there's like you're
surrounded in them there might be one in
your car it's it's incredible and every
one of those of course has to come back
at some point it's another opportunity
to recover it and harvest it
so as we look forward you know our focus
is on you know production on scaling our
whole operation you know we're aiming at
enough production for about a million
vehicles per year of cathode and anode
copper foils you know this is sort of
our you know our trajectory that we're
heading toward it's a lot of capital
it's a lot of growth and development but
this is you know a meaningful scale and
it's something that can actually move
the needle on the overall cost and
Emissions for these raw materials in the
country and in in the world
and I believe the same system as we're
building and architecting kind of just
like supercharging and just like early
Roadster battery architecture they feel
broadly relevant to me you know even
though this is sort of the very
beginning of you know having enough
traction to start to build a closed-loop
ecosystem for batteries I think if we
were sitting here in 20 or 30 years it's
going to be patently obvious that most
of the materials in batteries will be
recycled most of them will be in a
closed loop
and once the whole Fleet is in a steady
state that Loop that's going around the
remanufacturing will be much larger than
all the lithium and nickel and copper
mining that surfaces it today it's just
it's just math
so it was shocking to me that more
companies weren't working on this so
this is a quick little snapshot of kind
of our progress to date we'll let this
run but it gives you a more visual
indication of what we've been up to and
what we're doing
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you all